almost eight years after the financial
crisis spotlighted the more than
occasionally murky practices of Wall
Street the industry likes to point out
that bad behavior is behind it is that
true not according to a new report that
surveyed financial professionals own
views of their industry it found among
other shocking conclusions almost half
think their competitors have engaged in
unethical or illegal activity in order
to gain an edge in the market while the
quarter believe co-workers have engaged
in similar activity and a third of those
earning half a million dollars or more
have witnessed or have first-hand
knowledge of wrongdoing in the workplace
one of the people behind that report is
here Thomas Jordan Thomas pardon me of
the law firm Labbit on sutro Jordan what
do these findings in your opinion tell
us about Wall Street well it appears
that wall street has lost its moral
compass and wait a second when did lost
when did Wall Street last have its moral
compass well what I was going to say
next was in question and they're still
looking for it because the survey almost
all the statistics from 2013 when we did
a similar survey to now have gotten much
worse and one more time who exactly is
being surveyed financial service
professionals in the US and the United
Kingdom we're talking about traders sure
invest money managers I bankers exactly
and these are people who have stayed in
their jobs so tonight people have left
the industry they were there or bidar
the crisis during the crisis and they're
there now yes and haven't changed their
behavior and have stayed in these
institutions that they deem unethical
but they're not doing anything about it
one of the things that we see in the
financial services industry survey is
that many people are aware of wrongdoing
many people feel pressured to engage in
wrongdoing but many people are not
speaking up okay well institutions are
comprised by are led by people
individuals they're not inanimate
objects if all of those people surveyed
think the behavior is bad then isn't the
onus upon them to change it absolutely
absolutely I think one of the one of the
issues that wasn't known until today was
that corporations around the country
have been using secrecy agreements and
secrecy policies to prohibit their
employees from speaking up about
wrongdoing which may explain why some
fair point really but it does raise an
important question and I need you to
answer it because there are some people
out there Jordan who know that lapit on
sucharow you know files lawsuits on
behalf of shareholders has a
whistleblower practice for example where
you represent whistleblowers and they
might be saying to themselves well these
are convenient conclusions to come to
for a firm like yours sure I think that
they should have comfort with the fact
that Notre Dame conducted the survey it
was the largest survey of its you guys
paid for it but Notre Dame did it
correct and and at the end of the day
what people should be focusing on is
that there's a problem on Wall Street
until until we accept that we're not
going to be able to see significant
change uh but you're not evaluating
other industries so could one make the
argument well it's only Wall Street
that's unethical but if you're not
looking at any other businesses out
there how could you say it's any worse
than any other industry in corporate
America you know that's a great point I
think that our focus is on the financial
services industry because they are the
stewards of trillions of dollars of you
know citizens money and we wanted to
focus on that group and it because they
have deposits they fulfill a different
role they're stewards of individuals
money how about government of government
officials those are elected officials
that should be protecting and
representing citizens what if you know
you're not doing an evaluation of their
honesty in their integrity and their
wrong doing so is it fair I'll hang on a
second American voters have a chance to
do that every time they go to the boy no
they might not have they might not know
all that goes on in there Steph Steph we
ask questions of the financial service
professionals not only of their industry
but their assessment of law enforcement
officials and the good news is that
their views are getting better there's
there's still room for improvement but
and the other positive sign here is that
people are we got to end it on so sorry
jordan thomas of lavet on sutro thank
you for bringing study too